so we're going to look at one games
today and the purpose of the class is to
teach you to not be dogmatic because
that's your problem
exactly okay so normally kids are
dogmatic and what they do is they don't
know very much because your kids and
what you do know you think is the truth
and if there's other truths but you
don't know those truths you're like I
don't know what that is so for example
you might think doubled pawns are bad
right but I could show you positions
where doubled pawns are good and then
you're like no double puns are bad okay
so this is a famous scheme because white
did something you're not supposed to do
fantasy but when needs in it it was
great and they said wow you're great
don't talk we're being recorded all
right so this is the game Nigel short
versus Yan Tim I'm Nigel short is from
what country I'll give you a hint his
first name is Nigel now somewhere
between America and Germany Mexico is
right between them the correct answer of
course is England okay now he's playing
yawns him on and yawn Simon is from
another country who never heard of the
Netherlands yeah also Turkey he's not
from Turkey because I'm a vegetarian I
don't show stuff from Turkey okay so
this game was played in 1991 1991 I
lived in Europe I lived in a country
that starts with B
Belarus is also an answer but Belgium is
the right answer
coincidentally Belgium is between the
Netherlands in England so perfect
don't tell the North Sea that okay you
with some crazy comment what Buffalo New
York no all right I was right about the
crazy comment
okay now this scheme not only did white
may break the known norms of not moving
your King up the board black broke the
norms of moving his knight 700 times in
a row now I'm going to give you a funny
analogy and you're going to laugh let's
say I wanted to beat that kid up in the
corner he's too far so I give up but if
I really needed to beat him up which is
possible I would have to go all the way
over there that ain't going to happen
or he could walk over here that would
that be better okay so that's what black
did black wants to take all of whites
pieces but light doesn't want to go all
the way to white side of the board so
blacks like come to my side of the board
then I'll take you so black played nine
to f6
notice how the knight is attacking the
pawn because I said so and white said
hey I'm going to move to your side of
the board and play e5 okay now White's
moving towards black so black can more
easily take him unfortunately blacks
making 100 Knight lose in a row now
these things happen okay they're
attacking the knight again so black made
a lot of knight moves right what would
Bob Seger's say he'd say he's working on
his Knight moves
okay so now you see this pawn that's all
up in Black's grille blacks attacking
that pawn twice okay Queen e2 defends
the pawn and black attacks it
again so blacks attacking this pawn
quite a bit right he's like cooking it
over here so I can take you okay white
castle's okay not white castle white
castles one's good and ones bad smarter
than usual okay this is some that you
could should be in church church's fried
chicken
even worse than White Castle but not
worse than white castling what is worse
than white castling all right now h3 a
move you'll never understand until I
explain it to you black wants to play
Bishop to g4 pinning the knight and
whites like nope now let's go back see I
went back let's pretend black plays
Bishop g4 pinning the knight you see
what I'm saying now black is losing
because White has a brilliant tactic
it's too hard for you nobody can solve
it you with the wrong answer
bishop
we'll love attacking bishop then a
reaction obviously
okay now let's go back to the planet
Earth and call on you let's go back to
this guy you hear he's making more sense
yeah you have to reverse your metaphors
you with the right answer you maybe look
you made me look so bad there I was so
confident I can be five only then knows
because it's all about the Benjamins
what should white play a brilliant
tactic you could never find yeah I
called on you
this should takes f7 check notice black
will take it then we play your move
because you speak some Russian right
yeah Knight g5 check notice the night
attacks the king the Queen attacks the
bishop so that's good for white so black
cancelled and now he's threatening
Bishop g4 and white who has played a lot
of German players said it's don't think
so
h3 putting it at age a 5 with the idea
of a for trapping the bishop so white
resigned now white played a four takes
takes 90 for a triple fork
I wonder what white did yeah of course
now remember when I tried to beat that
kid up in the corner but he's too far
away now we're going to beat this kid up
we got two guys on him right he came to
us rook he won
oh well he defended it darn East six
boob walking the bishop 92 I wonder
where that Knights going well yet f3
Queen in the middle trade Queens white
like I don't want to trade Queens b3
takes takes now we're threatening a
skewer if only you knew what a skewer
was that that's what it is
rikiei Rick do you on taking the open
file and white plays for checkmate
because checkmates good you win then
uh-oh that's pretty aggressive right
Bishop g7 okay now White's going for
checkmate all of whites pieces are
getting close to the black King and
there's one open file is it the a file
what file the D file and I think White
has the D file know what I mean
I don't think blacks Turks are very good
okay rook to e8 Queen Shaq here now
there's a world champion you never heard
of but you have a good excuse you've
never heard of any of the world
champions
that's good excuse okay let's see who
the smartest assist is who was the first
world champion
I will accept two answers the right
answer or you could say me I accept
either answer the correct answer is
Wilhelm Stein it's okay Steines let's
look him up let's see st carry the one
okay that guy he when he was born he
looked like that
he was always old all right
yeah that's these bored old now Stein
it's fought differently than everybody
else
he was like Apple except he was slightly
less evil nah just kidding
he was much less evil okay so Stein it
said the king should be active and he
moved his arms back and forth not sure
why most people say the king should be
safe
I'm afraid by opponents attacking me and
sign it's like hey my king is doing a
lot of good stuff now modern
grandmasters like myself thank you very
much in the opening we keep our Kings
safe and in the endgame our King takes
all your pieces Stein this is like I
don't care if it's the opening or middle
gamer endgame my King should be active
okay don't listen to him then you get
checkmated now here Nigel short did
something very funny he said my queen is
really good my rooks are really good my
knight is blocking his Queen and Bishop
otherwise checkmate and my opponent
can't move Viswanathan my opponent's
pieces can't move there's only one white
piece that isn't active the King so
Nigel short did what we call a king
March right he decided if his King was
on h6 that Queen g7 mate would be a good
move you see what I'm saying
normally if your king is walking up here
the guys meeting you but which black
piece is going to mate white nothing
right okay so Nigel started pushing his
H pawn he's going to go here and give me
didn't black allow that of course not so
black played he stopped this
yeah he played aged five okay and then
Nigel is like I have a good idea
King age - okay King g3 King f4 what's
he doing he's doing what I showed you
King g5 and if Bishop takes rook then
King h6 and then there's no defense to
checkmate
now I'm going to show you a funny trick
but no crying what's the only move that
stops King age six bathrooms over there
you King age seven now white hasn't
moved this so good most of you will cry
obviously rook takes f7 wins in fact
rook takes f7 might be the best move but
there's a much cooler move if you're one
of the cool kids you here then King
takes Queen well yay for somebody I
would say nay
but I'm horsing around hey one of you
got it you with the right answer Queen
takes g6
shocking everyone especially the person
who answered it yeah let's see how that
works
hey it won't let me hey I won't yeah so
black didn't like the move King age 7
because not only does Benz move when
rook F 7 wins equally good and if you
don't play King age 7 King age 6 is
annoying so black did something you'll
never do he resigned gay how do I know
he resigned
it certainly could he resigned right so
is that what you guys do walk your King
up the answer is yes except this time it
was correct but we have an announcement
from our tournament director
you play the kids on their turn you have
not signed up yet do now yeah then you
can play in the tournament the more you
pay the more you learn right so if you
walk your King up and it was intentional
which is unusual that's because you're
trying to check me by using your King
and blacks pieces they're all talking a
badge they got nothing against this King
right that's the Al Capone of Kings
right no it's like Charlotte except
Charlotte's the Queen City this is the
king what maybe it makes dollars does it
make sense
look when I started lecturing in the
first class Green Bay was up 14-0 then
when my lecture ended it was 1410 that
doesn't make sense either that's what
happens so remember when you play in the
tournament later
make sure your king is safe and
sometimes when you walk your King up
it's still safe but usually not that's
why this is a famous game he walked his
king up at his King was safe and his
opponents wasn't and that funny he used
his king to attack which first world
champion you never heard of would be
proud of that game for Wyatt you very
good see somebody was listening
I wonder who was